a free trade deal with the u.s isn't
looking likely anytime soon so britain
might have to come up with another way
into the huge american market goods and
services exported to the us were worth
92.1 billion pounds in 2019 just on
goods the uk was the us's eighth largest
supplier america importing more than 46
billion pounds worth from britain in the
same year the biggest amounts for
vehicles machinery pharmaceuticals and
mineral fuels now one way to build on
that would be applying to be part of the
u.s mexico canada trade agreement that
was launched by donald trump britain
already has trade agreements with canada
and mexico but would obviously benefit
from the u.s bit of that deal but
analysts estimate that joining could add
only 0.1 to 0.2 per cent of gdp to the
british economy and the uk would not
have a say over the rules of the
agreement
another more contrived route could be
joining another trade bloc this one in
asia britain's applied to become a
member of the cp tpp that includes all
these asian countries if the u.s joins
in two that could be a back door to
closer u.s uk trade ties
so is this what boris johnson meant when
he talked about global britain punching
above its weight
no say the french their europe minister
says the uk is just becoming a vassal
state of the us in return the prime
minister has had a go at mangling the
french language
i just think it's it's it's time for
some of our dearest friends around the
world to you know prone and grip
about all this uh and don in break
that aside the johnson government knows
the ultimate goal is a direct us uk
trade deal and from the noises being
made in washington and new york this
week landing one is not getting any
easier